sous les réserves d'usagé monsieur le
premier ministre mesdames et messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues leur
religion rappelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
notre séance et retransmise en direct
sur public sénat sur notre site internet
au nom du bureau du sénat j'appelle
chacun à observer des valeurs
essentielles au sénat le respect des uns
et des autres et bien sûr du temps de
parole mais aussi le respect des gestes
sanitaires que nous ne devons pas
oublier qui me permet de saluer les
collègues qui acceptent d'être dans les
tribunes pour que nous obtenions la
jauge de présence la parole est
maintenant notre collègue joël labbé
pour le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoires
[Applaudissements]
si le président mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture
ce mardi la fondation nicolas hulot
présente a présenté une étude faisant
état du manque de cohérence entre les
financements publics agricoles et les
objectifs affichés de réduction des
pesticides
ces résultats ont déjà suscité une
polémique aussi ma question ne se
voudrait surtout pas être polémique elle
ne voudrait pas généré non plus une
réponse polémique
je voudrais simplement précisé que ce
constat de manque de cohérence recoupent
ceux de plusieurs rapports récents comme
celui de la cour des comptes qui jugeait
en 2020 la pac inégalitaire et source
d'effets pervers notamment sur la
consommation des pesticides ou encore le
rapport de francs stratégie qui propose
de réformer la pac pour diminuer
l'utilisation d'intrants et un réel
ajustement entre les aides publiques et
les efforts consentis par les par les
agriculteurs pratiquant l'agroécologie
ce constat d'un véritable déficit
d'accompagnement est ressenti par un
nombre croissant d'agriculteurs qui
seraient prêts à changer leurs pratiques
mais se sentent insuffisamment soutenu
financièrement dans un contexte de
course aux prix bas imposé par le
secteur agroalimentaire comme celui de
la grande distribution et aussi de
concurrence déloyale de produits
importés ne respectant pas les normes
européennes et françaises se posait
aussi monsieur le ministre je voudrais
vous poser trois questions dans le futur
plan national stratégique
prévoyez-vous d'augmenter le budget
destiné à rémunérer l'agriculture
biologique dont la performance
économique social et environnemental est
aujourd'hui arrivée avait réparé dont la
seconde question concerne les dotations
jeunes agriculteurs comment profiter de
ce moment de renouvellement de
génération pour accélérer la transition
vers l'agroécologie et la troisième sur
le ministre et j'en termine sur la
question des dettes des importations que
ne respectant pas nous
nos normes qui sont scandaleuses
monsieur le ministre est vous allez en
profiter du plan stratégique pour
l'intégrer je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole et au ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
monsieur julien de normandie merci
beaucoup monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur la baie il est
impératif de cesser d'opposer
agriculture et environnement
c'est à la fois injuste et puis je vais
vous le dire c'est totalement aberrant
c'est totalement abérrant parce que les
agriculteurs y vivent de l'environnement
les agriculteurs y chiris la terre il
protège le sol
et puis je vais vous dire aussi les
agriculteurs
contrairement à ce que certains
cherchent à véhiculer ils font de cette
transition
songez monsieur le sénateur que
l'utilisation de ces produits si vous
prenez la totalité de la période
-30 6% dans les ventes les produits les
plus dangereux - 70%
elle est là la réalité monsieur le
sénateur et puis qui dit qui dit que
encore plus que la forêt ce qui inquiète
le plus le carbone sur terre après la
mer c'est le sol ce qui aujourd'hui
agissent pour lutter avec efficacité
contre le changement climatique
ce sont nos agriculteurs mais ça
personne ne le dit dans le débat
donc arrêtons d'opposer agriculteurs et
environnement et puis en fait il faut
arrêter d'être dans l'injonction qui
plus est vis-à-vis de personnes qui en
moyenne et c'est pas le ministre qu'il
dit c'est l'insee travail 55 heures par
semaine en moyenne
pour faire quoi pour faire cette plus
noble mission qui est de nourrir le
peuple français elle est là la réalité
monsieur le sénateur et enfin si on ne
veut pas opposer agriculture et
environnement
c'est parce qu'il faut avoir une ligne
de conduite qui est clair c'est la
création de valeur au moment où on crée
de la valeur pour protéger
l'environnement
il faut créer de la valeur pour nos
agriculteurs il faut oser dire que le
compte de résultat de nos agriculteurs
il est important on ne fera pas
transition agro écologiques sans
agriculteurs on n'aura pas d'agriculture
sans agriculteurs et il n'y a pas au
monde monsieur le sénateur une nation
forte sans une agriculture forte
préservons la accompagnant la et soyons
en fiers
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue à la
marque
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires pour deux
minutes
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
santé
la france a adopté une attitude modules
et de lutte contre la pandémie au lieu
d'un confinement brutale cette décision
a été bien accueilli mais pose un
certain nombre de questions que
j'aimerais vous présenter sous la forme
d'un qcm qui vous rappellera monsieur le
ministre peut être leur temps de vos
études de médecine
5 au vide première question avez vous
réfléchi une stratégie vaccinale pour
les personnes de 65 à 74 ans sachant que
la haute autorité de santé ne recommande
pas de vacciner cette population avec le
vaccin d'astrazeneca
deuxième question la bavière impose
désormais l' usage des masques ffp2 dans
les transports en commun la plupart des
scientifiques semblent penser que c'est
une précaution superfétatoire mais à la
suite de la recommandation du haut
conseil de la santé publique
d'abandonner les masque en tissu de
mauvaise qualité et de leur interdiction
dans les écoles envisagez-vous de
généraliser l'interdiction des masques
en tissu de catégorie 2 au profit des
masques chirurgicaux
troisième question le gouvernement a
annoncé le déploiement prochain de tests
salivaires en milieu scolaire retour des
vacances d'hiver
prévoyez-vous de rendre ces tests
accessibles à l'ensemble de la
population et notamment sous la forme
d'auto test en effet des start up
française puis g us dont le juge a lu
quelques-unes ce matin ont développé des
tests salivaires validés par la haute
autorité de santé qui doivent être lus
par un professionnel de santé
certaines de ces startups serait
rapidement capacité de développer des
auto test salivaire qui permettront de
tester massivement la population
française à domicile le gouvernement est
il prêt à soutenir cette démarche
française de tests salivaires et
d'autotest dans quelles conditions
pourrait-il être généralisé est prise en
charge par la sécurité sociale
pour vous répondre la parole et ministre
des solidarités de la santé monsieur
olivier veyrat mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur à la marque vous
m'avez posé des questions précises je
vais vous faire des réponses les plus
précises possibles et plus costaud pour
les personnes entre 65 et 74 ans ce à ce
stade ce sont plutôt les vaccins arn
messagers c'est-à-dire finder moderna et
demain curva quand il sera validé qui
pourront être proposées le vaccin sera
zeneca n'a pas de recommandation vous
l'avez dit vous-même à ce stade mais si
les données scientifiques devaient
évoluer dans le bon sens alors la donne
pourrait évidemment changé vous me
demandez quand eh bien écoutez
logiquement d'ici à la fin mars au tout
début du mois d'avril nous aurons
vacciner la totalité de la population
cible âgé de 75 ans et plus et pourront
ouvrir la vaccination aux personnes
la tranche suivante parages décroissance
est à dire des 65-74 ans en vaccins arn
messagers en centre deuxième question
sur les masques le haut conseil de santé
publique demande à ne plus utiliser vous
l'avez dit vous-même les masque en tissu
non pas de mauvaise qualité
mais ce sont les masques et généralement
conte à fabriquer soi-même en est sûr de
suivre les normes afnor et dont le degré
d'infiltration n'est pas supérieur à 90%
en revanche la filtration à 90% est
assurée par les masques ffp2 les masques
chirurgicaux et les masques grand public
nommé catégorie 1 c'est à dire
l'écrasante majorité près de 100% des
masques que vous pouvez trouver dans le
commerce il n'y a donc pas lieu d'aller
vers une extension du port du masque
ffp2 il ya une région allemande qui l'a
fait ailleurs ça n'est pas le cas
troisième question les tests salivaires
accessible à la population
oui j'attends les recommandations de la
haute autorité de santé
ce soir avec des méthodes d'analysé en
pcr particulière les laboratoires se
prépare nous travaillons avec eux depuis
des semaines le public prioritaire ce
sont les enfants dans nos écoles de
manière à pouvoir identifier sans
désagrément pour les enfants des cas
positifs et donc protéger et préserver
l'école dont nous souhaitons qu'elle
puisse rester ouverte le plus longtemps
possible
il y aura déjà les premiers tests
salivaires à partir de demain
par les hôpitaux de paris et dès la mi
février nous emmènerons 200 à 300 milles
par semaine dernière question les auto
test salivaire hélas monsieur le
sénateur c'est là qu il y a un souci
c'est que la sensibilité de ces tests
est de l'ordre de 11 à 40 % pour les
meilleurs d'entre eux c'est à dire si
vous jetez une pièce en l'air vous avez
plus de chance d'avoir la vérité à
savoir si vous êtes positif ou négatif
la recherche continue la recherche
continue en france et ailleurs
aucun pays européens utilisent
réellement s'est auto test à ce stade le
japon déploie un certain nombre d'autos
test nous travaillons avec eux conclut
moi et moi dès que nous en aurons nous
les utiliserons ce sera un game change
heures je vous remercie monsieur bart
quelques secondes des starters française
notamment en régions occitanes y sont en
train de travailler là-dessus
j'espère que vous avez une oreille
attentive monsieur les ministres n'ont
pas leurs doléances mais à leur résultat
qui me semble-t-il ne sommes pas si
négatif que cela
merci la parole et à notre collègue
philippe dallier pour le groupe les
règlements ça madame la ministre du
logement les chiffres du nombre de
logements sociaux financés en 2020 sont
tombés ils sont très mauvaise et un
recul historique
certes il ya eu la crise du covili a eu
le cycle électoral des municipales qui a
été prolongée de trois mois mais il ya
certainement d'autres facteurs thierry
repentin le président de la commission
nationale sru dans un rapport qu'il a
rendu au gouvernement à sa demande en
pointe deux facteurs la suppression de
la taxe d'habitation cette année est
l'exonération du foncier bâti dont
bénéficient les bailleurs sociaux qui va
jouer et il ya un autre facteur le
découragement des maires qui ont envie
de construire ils sont très majoritaires
face aux objectifs de la loi sru actuels
qui sont devenus inatteignable tout le
monde le sait thierry repentin a fait
deux propositions au gouvernement pour
modifier cette loi sru
alors madame la ministre j'aimerais
savoir quelle est la solution que le
gouvernement entend retenir s'il entend
retenir une et surtout dans quel
calendrier parlementaire vous entendez
effectivement mettre en oeuvre cette
nouvelle solution
pour vous répondre la parole et à madame
la ministre de la transition et
écologique pour la mobilité
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur
sénateurs d'allier je voudrais d'abord
rappeler en préambule que 70 à 80 % des
français sont éligibles au logement
social et face à la crise que nous
traversons il est essentiel de faire
mieux et de construire plus de logements
sociaux
c'est l'objet de la loi sru qui a 20 ans
cette année
saluant la longévité la pertinence de
cette fois et de son emblématique
article 55 plus de 1,8 million de
logements ont été ainsi produit depuis
2001 dont près de 900 milles dans les
communes déficitaires et soumise en
rattrapage et ça c'est un acquis que
nous pouvons tous salué sur les 1000 64
communes soumises à l'obligation sru la
moitié d'entre elles suivent une
trajectoire vertueuse et pourrait
atteindre leurs objectifs d'ici 2025
cependant oui il y à certaines communes
qu'il n'y arrive pas et qui manque
parfois aussi de volontarisme sur le
sujet ainsi dans le cadre du bilan de la
période triennale 2017 2019
le gouvernement a donné des consignes de
fermeté sur les 550 commune n'ayant pas
atteint leurs objectifs plus de la
moitié on était carencée avec parfois
des reprises de permis de construire
nous sommes vigilants à ce que les
efforts se poursuivent tout en nous
mobilisant pour accompagner les communes
concernées
enfin nous avons effectivement engagé un
travail sur l'avenir de la loi sru dont
l'échéance était est prévue fin 2010 25
ce qui conduirait à fixer en 2022 les
derniers objectifs de rattrapage il est
nécessaire de prolonger d'exigence
monsieur sénateur de la loi sru au delà
de 2025 pour poursuivre l'effort en
matière de répartition du parc social
il faut le faire en tenant compte des
situations locales en fixant des
objectifs ambitieux et atteignait
et on reste enfermé avec les communes
qui ne jouent pas le jeu
la ministre du logement emmanuelle
wargon a saisi la commission sru
présidée par thierry repentin qui comme
vous l'avait signifié a rendu un rapport
et a fait des propositions en ce sens
leur apporter public depuis la semaine
dernière c'est l'objet de consultations
et ses propositions pourraient trouver
une traduction législative
monsieur d'allier la parole peut-être je
m'adresser au ministre de l'agriculture
pour avoir une réponse plus précise si
le gouvernement n'agit pas et n'agit pas
rapidement
vous terminerez le quinquennat avec du
point de vue de la construction de
logements neufs que ça soit privé ou
sociaux avec des résultats
catastrophiques
alors que la seule loi que vous aurez
fait adopter s'appelait élan ouallam les
milices
le logement c'est un sujet fondamental
pour tous nos concitoyens nous sommes
dans une impasse
vous pouvez vous avez encore le temps de
bouger sur les exos tfpb mais également
sur l'article 55 de la loi sru fait le
malin beaucoup de maires sont prêts à
construire il faut les y aider ça n'est
pas seulement les coups de bâton qu'il
faut il faut les accompagner alors
faites le de grasse faite le
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue jean
pierre moga
jean pierre moga pour le groupe de
l'union centriste mais merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre
les inondations affectent le sud ouest
en particulier le département de
lot-et-garonne chaudes elles sont ces
inondations sont une catastrophe pour
ses habitants
le 3 février dernier la garonne a
atteint la cote de 9 et 5 en 2 h ommes
de 10 mètres 20 à marmande la salle le
département en vigilance rouge
une crue exceptionnelle comme monsieur
le ministre l'a constaté lors de son
déplacement en normandie
je tiens d'ailleurs à les en remercier
le temps qu'il a consacré à la
discussion avec les sinistrés
les élus et les services a été très
apprécié je souhaite saluer l'efficacité
la mobilisation des services du sis des
mères et de leurs équipes municipales
des centres auteurs et des services de
l'état
face à cette situation les élus ont
unanimement demandé que l'état de
catastrophe naturelle soit reconnue sur
l'ensemble des communes que le système
de prévision des crues qui globalement
fonctionne bien anticipe bien au delà de
cinq heures a minima 12 heures voire 24
heures ces élus ont insisté sur le
financement l'entretien et l'aménagement
des digues difficilement supportable
pour les budgets de nos petites
intercommunalités l'âge et mappy et les
papilles sont encore loin de tout régler
monsieur le ministre vous avez confirmé
qu'il y aura bien un soutien de l'état
pour les aides exceptionnelles
après cette crue par contre comment
assouplir les règles de curage des
fossés à la zone inondable afin de
faciliter l'évacuation de l'eau lors de
la décrue des milliers de mètres cubes
d'eau stagner des semaines dans les
champs comment aménager les territoires
et prévenir les futurs risques
climatiques comment améliorer le système
de prévision ou les systèmes de
prévisions voire stocker une partie de
cette eau des millions de mètres cubes
qui se passe pendant quelques jours sur
mon territoire et transformer la forte
la force
kata sismique de ces crus en énergie
hydraulique exploitables animaux que
pouvons nous dire à nos sinistre et
inquiets qui attendent une réponse là
les meilleurs délais je vous remercie
on vous raconte la parole et au ministre
de l'intérieur j'ai exprimé au nom du
sénat notre solidarité un certain nombre
d'élus particulièrement touché par ces
phénomènes d'inondation monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur permettez moi à mon tour au nom
du gouvernement de pouvoir exprimer
également la solidarité envers les
populations les élus les maires qui ont
été en premier les urgentistes de sa
situation auprès de leur population les
services de l'état vous l'avez dit les
pompiers les policiers les gendarmes les
agents des préfectures et tous ceux avec
les collectivités locales et qui ont
peut permettre la mobilisation pour
éviter un maximum de drames des drames
il y en a eu cependant des drames qui
touchent bien sûr les biens et vous
l'avez dit monsieur le premier ministre
avec la secrétaire d'état s'est rendue
dans cette partie de l'ouest de la
france et le sud ouest et l'ouest qui
sont touchés à la demande du premier
ministre les services du ministère de
l'intérieur et ceux de madame barbara
propice sont mobilisés et daisy hier
monsieur sénateurs une première
commission s'est réunie et il ya eu déjà
145 dossiers présentés qui ont été
acceptées vous savez bien que c'est les
communes vous le savez monsieur le
sénateur je le dis ici au sénateur cdh
aux communes de faire sa demande
individuellement déjà 145 qui ont été
acceptés et aucune n'a été refusé par
les services du ministère de l'intérieur
parfois des demandes complémentaires
sont sont demandés mais je peux vous
assurer qu'avec la ministre
nous allons pouvoir dans les prochaines
heures continuer à instruire et a
déclaré l'état de catastrophe naturelle
dans ces communes singulièrement dans
votre département puisqu'il ya déjà
cinquante six communes dans ce
département qui ont eu un avis favorable
ensuite vous évoquez la prévention
indépendamment du drame de la tempête
justin que notre territoire inconnu
cette prévention dudit travaillons c'est
surtout les services de madame barbara
broccoli qui travaillent un conseil de
défense écologique a décidé en février
2020 de pouvoir mettre un certain nombre
de dispositions dans les plans d'action
et fameux papy qui évite les inondations
et des augmentations budgétaires
extrêmement forte notamment du fonds
barnier qui je crois sera
le cas pour madame la ministre qui
pourra évoquer le même un certain nombre
d'améliorations très concrètes pour les
habitations et pour un certain nombre de
riverains dans les zones inondables
et puis enfin il ya un système d' alerte
à partir de l'année prochaine et suite à
leur idole j'ai pu annoncer au nom de la
sécurité civile avec la ministre qu'un
système à l'air tout à fait modernisée
qui permettra à toutes les populations
quelles que soient ses difficultés de
sécurité civile dont les inondations de
recevoir sur son téléphone en temps réel
les informations qu'ils évitent
évidemment les drames humains
merci la parole est un autre collègue
céline brulin pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologique jamais
la parole merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre nous vous avions
alerté sur les conséquences prévisibles
de vos calculs budgétaires en matière
scolaire
et bien c'est pire ici ce sont des
suppressions de classe en collège comme
dans celui de bourreau de
blangy-sur-bresle en seine maritime qui
en perd deux sur les 17 que compte
l'établissement
là c'est une baisse considérable
d'heures d'enseignement en lice et au
lycée lillebonne par exemple le résultat
de la soustraction ses 110 heures de
moins pour une diminution de 22 élèves
seulement ce théorème vaut aussi en
primaire et en maternelle y compris en
éducation prioritaire
après avoir subi le traumatisme de deux
confinement l'éducation nationale va
nous faire subir un troisième
électrochoc may cry le maire de brachy
commune qui vient de réaliser un nouveau
groupe scolaire et savez vous pourquoi
cette commune à réaliser cet équipement
pour répondre à vos injonctions de
regrouper les écoles injonction qui font
si mal à nos communes rurales et qui se
voit bien mal récompensé une classe
devrait ainsi faire mais dans cette
commune
je pourrais multiplier ces exemples dans
toutes les académies de france partout
émerge la demande d'une carte scolaire
qui prenne en compte la situation
sanitaire et le besoin d'accompagnement
renforcé des élèves à l'image des plus
de 200 élus normands qui vous lance un
appel en ce sens la crise sanitaire née
pas derrière nous les inégalités
scolaires les inégalités sociales
encore moins monsieur le ministre allez
vous abandonnez l'arithmétique de choix
comptables déconnecté de la réalité pour
faire une équation positive de la carte
scolaire pour vous répondre la parole
les thomistes l'éducation nationale de
la jeunesse et les sports monsieur blanc
caire merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
entament la sénatrice brulin vous le
savez nous continuons à créer des postes
à l'école primaire alors même qu'il ya
moins d'élèves dans le cas de votre
département c'est plus d'un millier
d'élèves en moins l'année prochaine à
l'école primaire c'est la création de
près de 20 postes
donc je vous le dis l'ars en seine
maritime
à la rentrée prochaine le taux
d'encadrement va battre un record
historique
vous n'aurez jamais autant de
professeurs par rapport au nombre
d'élèves à l'école primaire donc et ceci
est vrai dans chaque département de
france
alors voulez vous dites est ce que vous
tenez compte de la de la crise sanitaire
la réponse est oui nous l'avons fait
notamment la rentrée précédente avec la
mesure ne décolle pas d'écoles fermées
ni de classes fermées sans
l'autorisation du maire cette mesure
nous avions dit aussi que ensuite ce
serait forcément sur pas d'écoles
fermées qu'elle porterait sans l'accord
du maire et même s'agissant des classes
il ya une consultation très forte par
rapport aux exemples que vous citez
comme vous le savez aussi les
consultations continuent et d'ailleurs
jusqu'à la veille de la rentrée elle
continue puisque nous tenant compte du
nombre d'élèves
nous mettons en oeuvre des mesures qui
sont qualitatives c'est pas l'esprit
comptable contrairement à ce que vous
avez dit exemple dans votre département
le dédoublement des grandes sections de
maternelle continue donc douze élèves
par classe dans certaines sections de
grande section de maternelle et dans
votre département
comme dans beaucoup de départements la
mesure pas plus de 24 élèves par classe
en grande section cp et en ce1
s'accomplit ce sont des progrès
considérables jamais l'école primaire
n'a fait l'objet d'une telle priorité
budgétaire
donc on peut ça c'est une vérité que
chacun peut vérifier dans le projet de
loi de finances s'est pas c'est pas une
opinion c'est un fait une réalité donc
taux historique d'encadrement les côtes
rire bien sûr il peut y avoir çà et là
des classes fermées vous savez très bien
ça nous renvoie des démographies rural
complexe je n'encourage pas
particulièrement le regroupement de
classes chaque cas est un cas
particulier qui de leurs grandes écoles
pardon chaque cas est un cas particulier
qui doit se voir avec les maires et la
consigne vous le savez et toute
exception doivent être signalés c'est le
travail conjoint avec les maires
évidemment dans la recherche du
consensus et de l'intérêt des élèves
[Applaudissements]
d'abord monsieur le ministre en guise de
records historiques en seine-maritime je
voudrais vous signaler mais vous le
savez mieux que moi que notre
département est encore en retard en
termes de taux d'encadrement à l'échelle
de la france
et puis vous n'avez absolument pas
répondu concernant les collèges et les
lycées où c'est un véritable carnage
entendez ce qui monte de partout en
france accorder des postes à corte des
heures et cesser de nous dire que les
heures supplémentaires vont compenser il
y en a eu 12 millions en 2019 de non
compensés de non assurés
c'est à dire des enseignements qui
manque à nos jeunes c'est absolument
intolérable dans la période que nous
connaissons où ces jeunes alternent
enseignement en présentiel et en
distance yale je vous remercie
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue martin lévriers pour le groupe
du rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendant merci
monsieur le président madame nice du
travail de l'emploi et de l'insertion
mes chers collègues
c'est historique plus de 500 mille
contrats d'apprentissage ont été signés
soit une hausse de 40% par rapport à
2010 9
dans mon département les yvelines le
nombre de contrats d'apprentissage a
enregistré une hausse de près de 42%
passant de 6551 à 9300 aux contrats
signés en l'espace de deux ans ces
chiffres sont le reflet de la
mobilisation du gouvernement en faveur
de la jeunesse
si votre prédécesseur muriel pénicaud je
la salue a amorcé grâce à la loi avenir
professionnel de septembre 2018
cette révolution copernicienne en
transformant le regard sur
l'apprentissage et en libéralisant le
système notamment via le transfert du
pilotage l'apprentissage des régions
vers les branches professionnelles
vous avez madame la ministre du travail
repris le flambeau avec brio vous avez
su
vous avez su malgré la crise sanitaire
économique et social maintenir et
accompagner la montée en puissance de
cette voie d'excellence en instaurant en
2020 et des aides exceptionnelles alors
de 5000 à 8000 euros selon les
situations
pour les entreprises qui embauchent un
apprenti
aujourd'hui alors que la jeunesse est
touchée par les conséquences économiques
de la crise sanitaire
ce record revêt une importance cruciale
il doit être le stimulus qui nous
amènera à trouver une solution adaptée à
chacun de nos jeunes pour leur garantir
la même réussite et le même
épanouissement que nos cinq cent mille
apprentis vous l'avez dit à de
nombreuses reprises mais je le rappelle
aucun ne doit rester sur le bord de la
route
ce succès n'est qu'une étape
supplémentaire dans le développement de
l'apprentissage
alors que la crise n'a toujours pas dit
son dernier mot
madame la ministre dans quelle dynamique
s'inscrivent aux futurs travaux pour
continuer de promouvoir l'ensemble de
ces mesures auprès de ces publics qui de
par leur formation seront un des
mouchoirs à 800 mhz l'après crise et des
croissances de l'entreprise
je vous remercie
vous répondre le
pour vous répondre la parole à madame la
ministre du travail de l'emploi de la
chaire sur madame bornes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur lévriers les bonnes nouvelles
mérite d'être répétée
alors en effet 2020 2020 est un record
historique pour l'apprentissage dans
notre pays un record inespéré dans cette
période de crise et je pense que chacun
sur ses bancs pourrait s'en réjouir
alors effectivement en 2020 ce sont plus
de 500 mille jeunes qui se sont engagés
dans l'apprentissage soit 140 milles de
plus qu'en 2019
cette augmentation traduit un effort
exceptionnel des ses efforts et une
mobilisation sans précédent des
entreprises alors oui cette dynamique
nous la devons aux transformations
structurelles de la loi pour la liberté
de choisir son avenir professionnel
voter en 2018 qui a permis de lever les
freins et de mieux adapter les
formations aux besoins des entreprises
mais pour maintenir cet élan dans un
contexte de crise le gouvernement a fait
le choix dès juillet de placer
l'apprentissage au coeur du plan un
jeune une solution avec des primes de
5000 à 8000 euros pour les entreprises
et des entreprises de toutes tailles
s'en sont saisis et elles ont été
décisifs pour les tpe et les pme qui ont
pu maintenir leur part prépondérante
dans l'accueil des jeunes en
apprentissage
je rappelle clean est de 3000 euros est
également prévu pour les collectivités
locales
et je les invite à s'en saisir et je
précise que c'est elle en positif a pu
profiter à l'ensemble de nos territoires
pour réussir la rentrée 2021 une
concertation s'engagera prochainement
avec les partenaires sociaux afin
d'adapter les aides au contexte actuel
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
notre politique en faveur de
l'apprentissage est plus que jamais
nécessaire et je vous invite à la porte
et dans nos territoires joue à merci la
parole est maintenant notre collègue
rachid tu es mal
le groupe socialiste et écologiste vous
avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre le 18
novembre dernier ici-même j'évoquais la
lueur d'espoir qui constitue l annonce
des vaccins et je vous interrogeait sur
la stratégie vaccinale du gouvernement
tout en faisant des propositions
la réponse fut simple et limpide la
france est prête à vacciner
malheureusement les français constatent
que cela n'a pas été ce qui a été
annoncé ne s'est pas déroulé comme prévu
mes objectifs de ré personnes vaccinées
sont régulièrement revus à la baisse
laissant de la station manque de doses
et le vaccin français reste introuvable
s'y ajoute l'absence de réponse du décès
at il est président du groupe socialiste
à l'assemblée au sénat patrick hannais
rival et rabaud demandant que
transparence soit faite sur les contrats
passés avec l'industrie pharmaceutique
cette situation ne peut et ne doit pas
perdurer nous sommes dans une course
poursuite en france en europe et dans le
monde entre la vaccination et le virus
avec ces variants aussi pour reprendre
l'expression du présent un public sur la
guerre à mener contre le virus il nous
devons mettre en place une économie de
guerre
donc j'ai deux questions la première
allez vous enfin engagé réellement la
bataille pour obtenir la levée des
licences sur les vaccins ou en cas de
refus d'industrie pharmaceutique faire
appel à licences d'office
ensuite allez vous investir massivement
en france afin de plus d'avoir des fous
des chaînes de production des vaccins
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et aux milices des solidarités de
la sorte et monsieur verrons
monsieur le le sénateur rachid tu es mal
pardon mais avant de poser des questions
vous avez dit un certain nombre de
choses venir les objectifs ont été revus
à la baisse je rappelle les objectifs
nous les avons annoncé devant les
français avec le premier ministre dit
c'est la fin du à la fin du d'ici à la
fin du mois de février 2,4 à 4 millions
de français ont reçu une première
injection
je suis en mesure de vous dire
aujourd'hui que d'ici la fin du mois de
février entre 3,5 et 4 millions de
français on reçu une première injection
pour effet renom mais on nous sommes
bien dans les objectifs qui n'ont pas
été revus à la baisse
la transparence n'a pas été faite sur
les contrats des laboratoires moi je
connais le prix d'achat le nombre de
doses les dates de livraison et nombre
de pays qui ont acheté le prorata par
rapport à la population les date d'achat
les dates de négociation et la
nationalité des personnes qui sont
allées en médiation pour le compte de la
commission européenne contractualiser
que les laboratoires en mon sens s'il
vous manque d information vous pouvez
nous les demander
quand vous dites qu'il ya un manque de
doses aujourd'hui la transparence est
fait sur quatre semaines est bientôt sur
huit semaines et chaque centre c'est
combien de doses ils disposent de
combien de doses ils disposent et peut
donc prendre des rendez-vous nécessaires
allant coup s'il ya un manque de dos et
qu'on voudrait avoir autant de doses
qu'il en faudrait pour vacciner toute la
population mais les centres ne manque
pas de dos puisque par définition les
adaptent leur credo de rendez vous aux
doses qu'il reçoive à nouveau
je redis je redis je redis les choses
sur le sénateur je redis les choses les
les centres n'ont pas assez de vaccins
aujourd'hui pour activer toute la
population française d'un coup c'est
pareil partout dans le monde mais les
centres savent pertinemment combien de
doses il reçoit pour les quatre
prochaines semaines et peuvent adapter
leur rendez vous pouvez balayé de la
main mais encore une fois je dis
j'essaie de vous répondre monsieur le
sénateur sur la question la licence
officielle n'est pas nécessaire dans la
mesure où les laboratoires qui dispose
de brevets pour produire les vaccins
nous permettent et nous incite
d'ailleurs à développer des sources de
production en france en europe et dans
le monde
on y travaille avec agnès pannier rue
nash et à nous fait non de la tête mais
c'est une vérité il ya quatre industries
quatre entreprises en france qui
produisent des vaccins pour le compte de
laboratoires qui disposait brevets la
question de la licence office elle se
pose monsieur le sénateur lorsqu'un
laboratoire dispose un monopole et dit
c'est moi qui règle la distribution le
prix et vous n'avez rien à voir avec ça
là c'est tout l'un verse et nous
accompagnons les entreprises pour
qu'elles puissent produire des vaccins à
la demande même des laboratoires et des
états monsieur clé balle alors là on est
dans le monde youri c'est assez
extraordinaire
donc il n'y a donc pas de problème de
vaccins en france je crois que chacun
peut le noter il n'y a pas de problème
de doses dans les centres de vaccination
d'ailleurs vous le dites vous même il
faut donc réadapter pourrait bien tout
ça ne tient pas sérieusement la route
donc encore une fois et vos chiffres
annoncés à l'automne ont été revus en
permanence à la baisse je vous le
réaffirmer ou prendront les dates si
vous le souhaitez résultat des courses à
par vous même à part vous même tous les
français consacrent ce problème sur la
vaccination sur la partie des brevets je
vous rappelle que là où c'est assez
intéressant c'est que le génome viral
n'a pas été lui breveté pour paraîtra le
6 pharmaceutique de pouvoir les
développer
c'est dan aux faits a breveté par contre
s'est propulsé ses productions dont ce
qu'on dit simplement c'est que si on
veut aujourd'hui vacciner l'ensemble des
français l'ensemble du monde pour avoir
moins de virus il faudra bien plus de 2
et donc il faut plus de chiens de
production encore une fois vous rester
enfermé dans vos certitudes
merci monsieur bargeton la parole est
maintenant notre collègue jean yves le
roux pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen donne la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues depuis le 30 octobre le
thermalisme est la seule offre de santé
remboursées par la sécurité sociale
inaccessible à nos concitoyens six cent
mille curistes atteints de maladies
chroniques de dépression d'obésité
accueillis dans 90 stations dédiées
nommé l'ifi plus d'aucun soin terme a
aujourd'hui 80 ans après leur fermeture
les douleurs chroniques les symptômes
des curistes n'ose pas subitement
disparu en 2020 comment prouver nous
soulager ses patients devant nous les
envoyer à l'hôpital déjà surchargé
pourrons-nous continuer de traiter
certaines infections entre temps que par
des médicaments parfois inefficaces sur
le plan économique les établissements
écuries sont réalisé 35% de leur chiffre
d'affaires en 2020 et leur trésorerie
affichant 110 millions de pertes c'est
exact
malheureusement les conséquences sont
déjà connus des dépôts de bilans
annoncés ainsi que des mesures de
sauvegarde
dix mille emplois directs non
délocalisables 100000 1.1 du vivant de
la filière thermales sont directement
menacés de disparition
en matière de développement territorial
avec mes collègues du groupe rdse nous
vous rappelons que 90% des termes sont
situées dans des villes de moins de
10000 habitants atteignant tout un
écosystème qui va cyr
ces dernières années les villes de
terrebonne ont un effet beaucoup investi
et leur projet de territoire marque un
véritable coup d'arrêt faute de recettes
suffisantes et prévisible sans
compensations spécifiques
messieurs les ministres le respect de la
santé des patients est dans l'adn de ces
établissements des tests pcr au début de
la curée ci conteste un cours du cur
assorti de mesures strictes de
déplacement peuvent
va être mené ce protocole a fait ses
preuves cet été puisqu'aucun cluster n'a
été constatée sur ce site
monsieur le ministre dans un contexte de
malaise certains de nos concitoyens
le thermalisme est un allié comment
pouvez vous permettre aux établissements
thermaux avec le concours des villes
d'eau à continuer d'assurer leurs
missions aux soins je vous remercie
la parole est aux phillies et legear
charge du commerce extérieur de
l'attractivité monsieur riester bien
merci monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur roues le
thermalisme comme d'ailleurs tout le
secteur du tourisme est touchée d'une
façon très durs par la crise du co lead
les 110 stations thermales de notre pays
a enregistré une perte d'activité de
l'ordre de 70% et donc vous avez raison
c'est un sujet qui est un sujet majeur
et le gouvernement a dès le départ fait
en sorte de d'ériger le tourisme et donc
les stations thermales en priorité
nationale
le secteur thermale a pu bénéficier à ce
titre de l'ensemble des mesures
d'accompagnement pour le secteur le
gouvernement d'ailleurs n'a cessé de
renforcer ses mesures
extension de la prise en charge
l'activité partielle aux établissements
thermaux exploités sous forme de régie
élargissement du fonds de solidarité
depuis décembre 2020 permettant
l'indemnisation sans limite d'effectifs
des entreprises ayant perdu 70 % de leur
chiffre d'affaires à hauteur de 20% en
2019 mise en place d'un nouveau
dispositif de compensation de 70% des
coûts fixes et pour l'avenir un
accompagnement du secteur sur le long
terme avec une enveloppe spécifique de
300 millions d'euros a été identifié
dans le plan de relance tourisme sur
proposition du secrétaire d'état au
tourisme jean baptiste lemoyne le
premier ministre a pris la décision de
confier une mission à jean yves
gouttebel président du conseil
départemental du puy de dôme afin de
faire des propositions structurantes
pour soutenir et transformer la filière
thermale française
vous voyez monsieur le sénateur que le
gouvernement est mobilisée au service de
ce secteur d'activité qui a un défi de
résistance à la crise est un défi bien
évidemment de relance pour en faire
demain à nouveau un des piliers du
tourisme pour que la france retrouve
rapidement le premier rang des
destinations mondiales en matière de
tourisme
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
arnaud bazin pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
le week-end dernier une énième zone à
défendre une zad s'est une nouvelle fois
installées en toute illégalité sur des
terrains appartenant à l'état sur des
emprises dédié à l'aménagement de la zac
du triangle de gonesse dans le val
d'oise sur ce secteur devait s'implanter
le projet europa city sacrifiait
l'automne 2010 9 par le président de la
république et le gouvernement de
l'époque en un mauvais remake de notre
dame des landes
plus de dix ans de promesses autant
d'années de travail et d'investissement
avait alors été rogné ainsi que les
importantes perspectives de
développement et d'emplois pour ces
territoires oubliés de la république
là aussi désolante rengaine mais cruelle
réalité
malgré ce reniement lourdes conséquences
sur la crédibilité de la parole publique
et la confiance des investisseurs
mais d'abord n'avait tenu à réitérer son
engagement de mener à bien
je la cite la desserte du territoire
prévu par la ligne 17 du métro du grand
paris et a encouragé les parties
prenantes à se remobiliser pour un autre
projet de développement
pourtant malgré cette décision prise
sous l' empire d'une vision malthusienne
de l'écologie dont je déplore qu'elle
est infiltrée l'état les opposants n'ont
pas désarmé
au contraire puisque aujourd'hui
une fois encore ils défient ouvertement
l'autorité de l'état
désormais ils s'en prennent aux
chantiers de n 10 est tout entière en
bloquant le puits du tunnelier
ils prétextent un vague projet de
jardinage périurbain en tant
qu'alternative il ne voulait pas d'un
disneyland pour consommateurs payé par
le grand capital
mais ils valent bien d'indicés a honte
de la courgette pour bobos payés par les
contribuables
sur le premier ministre allez-vous faire
respecter l'autorité de l'état et faire
évacuer ces délinquants garantissez-vous
le bon déroulement des travaux de la
ligne 17
ciao remercie on veut répondre la parole
est à la vie lisse de la transition
écologique
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur sénateurs arnaud bazin le val
d'oise vous avez raison est un
territoire dans les enjeux soulève des
questions structurantes en matière
d'aménagement du territoire et nous
devons collectivement être en mesure
d'apporter des réponses de bon sens qui
concilie de développement économique et
les enjeux écologiques sur le fond sur
le fond je peux comprendre que des
militants souhaitent lutter contre
l'artificialisation des terres
simplement je pense que la méthode n'est
pas la bonne et je les engage à lever ce
blocage qui pénalise l'ensemble du
chantier de la ligne du grand paris
express chantier dont le calendrier est
et restera inchangé en ce qui concerne
maintenant les moyens de poursuivre le
développement économique et de
désenclavement en matière de transport
de cette zone populaire de l'est du val
d'oise moi j'ai la conviction que
l'écologie n'est en aucun cas un frein
mais un accélérateur du développement
économique et nous ne devons pas mettre
en opposition les deux l'abandon de
repas city c'est un abandon qui a été
décidé par le président la république
par le précédent gouvernement qui est
dans une logique qui va dans le même
sens que le projet de loi que je viens
de présenter en conseil des ministres ce
matin qui va lutter contre
l'artificialisation des terres puisque
l'artificialisation des terres est en
responsabilité et sur de nombreuses
aggravation des effets du changement
climatique et vous le savez bien sûr vos
territoires
dans ce cas le préfet du département a
formulé une proposition intéressante que
nous allons étudier de près nous
n'écartons aucun scénario y compris ce
qui permet d'éviter d'artificialité les
rares terres agricoles de cette partie
de l'île de france
mais bien entendu je suis tout à fait
disposé à rencontrer des parlementaires
les élus locaux les acteurs associatifs
les citoyens du territoire afin qu'on
puisse définir ensemble les meilleures
solutions pour désenclaver et développer
cette partie du val d'oise qui a besoin
de perspectives qui a besoin qu'on la
soutienne et vous aurez le soutien du
gouvernement
évidemment pour trouver les bonnes voies
de développement de ce territoire
mais cette c'est bonne voie
développement elles doivent se faire
avec tous ses acteurs
monsieur bazin quelques secondes j'avais
demandé à monsieur le premier ministre
de nous rassurer sur sa volonté à
expulser et j'ai entendu madame la
ministre
pompe il y demandait gentiment aux
délinquants de partir tranquillement je
suis rassuré pour le groupe socialiste
écologistes et républicains
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le garde des sceaux
apparemment il n'y pas la fête s'adresse
à monsieur le garde des sceaux et
concernant les problématiques liées au
chlordécone en guadeloupe et en
martinique
pour rappel le chlordécone est un
produit qui a été utilisée entre les
années 70 et 95 à peu près dans les
plantations de bananes c'est un produit
cancérigène
les liens de causalité ont été faits
concernant les pour les concerts de la
prostate
c'est aussi un produit qui est un
perturbateur endocrinien aujourd'hui en
guadeloupe et en martinique les voix
s'élèvent contre des mesures qui ont été
prises et justement et récemment
s'agissant de l'enquète parlementaires
faites par l'assemblée nationale en 2019
les documents versés justement lors de
cette enquête
eh bien ces documents ont été scellées
et le seront consultables qu'en 2044
je vous dis bien 2044 pire encore des
plaintes des associations
les associations écologistes mais des
élus et des parents de personnes
victimes du chlordécone
ces plaintes sont dans la voix justement
de l'art l'intégration en tout cas pas
ce qu'il y à une dissimulation avérée de
preuves
donc on ne veut pas tenir compte de la
situation on veux prescrire
on veux prescrire et je crois que c'est
vraiment injuste par rapport à aux
populations concernées s'agit si le
monsieur le ministre
le dc humiliation avérée de preuves
s'agit-il de déni de justice
s'agit-il d'un mépris à l'égard de ces
populations
j'attends votre réponse je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole et
mobilisent les solidarités de la chanter
monsieur olivier viron la sénatrice
jasmin merci pour votre question je
réponds pour le pour le garde des sceaux
mais aussi pour le ministre en charge de
l'outre-mer et pour moi-même
d'abord vous dire que nous avons tous
conscience que le chlordécone pardon
pour l'expression était une vraie salle
tu es une vraie saloperie qui étaient
utilisés dans les années 70 dans les
années 80 qui a pourri les seuls qui a
un effet rémanent pendant six ans en qui
peut contaminer les milieux aquatiques
les sols les denrées alimentaires et
pour laquelle l'état français s'est déjà
engagé à plusieurs reprises à travers
trois plans et j'y reviendrai à travers
un quatrième plan vous le savez puisque
le présent la république pour la
première fois en déplacement aux
antilles c'est la première fois qu'un
président la république s'engage est
autant sur ce sujet d'abord tout vous
dire je partage la très forte émotion
que suscite les faits que vous évoquez
que le gouvernement est mobilisé et
évidemment pour les faits que vous avez
évoqué vous l'avez dit ils font
actuellement l'objet d'une information
judiciaire qui est suivi par le pôle de
santé publique du tribunal de paris
des juges d'instruction ont été désignés
de façon à suivre ce dossier en octobre
2008 après jonction des procédures
initialement ouverte aux antilles ce
sont les services de l'office central de
lutte contre les atteintes lutte aux
atteintes à l'environnement et à la
santé publique ainsi que les sections de
recherches de la gendarmerie de
martinique et guadeloupe qui sont saisis
de l'enquêté sur commission rogatoire
vous rappeler que les juges
d'instruction
et signalé aux parties civiles la
possible prescription de l'action
publique dans ce dossier encore une fois
je comprends
nous comprenons la légitime émotion de
la population et des victimes de cette
terrible pollution qui veulent obtenir à
juste titre des réponses à leurs
questions qui sont légitimes
comme vous le savez le gouvernement ne
peut pas interférer interférer dans une
procédure judiciaire en cours
il même là commenté de quelques manières
que ce soit en vertu du principe
d'indépendance de l'autorité judiciaire
pour autant le gouvernement n'a cessé
d'oeuvrer sur le sujet pour les victimes
aux côtés des élus aux côtés des
parlementaires un pas essentiel sera
franchie puisque c'est cette fois avec
la participation de la société civile
des associations mais aussi des
particuliers que les nouveaux axes et
priorités de lutte contre la pollution
par la chlordécone et de ses effets que
le plan chlordécone 4 a été construit et
les moyens qui seront consacrés seront
presque doublé ce plan est d'ailleurs en
cours d'adoption une directrice de
projet vient d'être nommé avec un rôle
très opérationnels et interministérielle
qui va permettre d'améliorer le suivi
entre le national et le local
c'était l'une des propositions phares
madame la sénatrice du rapport de la
commission denquête de votre collègue
justine bénin présidée par serge
letchimy dont je tiens à saluer la
qualité des travaux
je vous remercie sma je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre mais je m'interroge
mêmes causes peuvent pourtant pour
produire les mêmes effets vous avez très
récemment déroger aux règles concernant
les néonicotinoïdes ce sont les mêmes
sujets les mêmes sujets monsieur le
ministre
donc ce que vous pouvez y est pour les
antilles probable mais les lentes
néonicotinoïdes pourquoi dérogé à leur
utilisation parole
à l'autre collègue une souris pour le
groupe l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues l' agence
nationale de la sécurité des systèmes
d'information l'anzhi a recensé une
explosion du nombre de cyber attaques en
quatre fois plus qu'en 2019 dans la
majorité des cas les cybercriminels
utilisent des logiciels afin de crypter
les données de leurs victimes
rendant inutilisables tout ou partie
leurs architectures informatiques
les pirates monnaie ensuite les données
volées contre le paiement d'une rançon
particulier entreprise service public
personne est épargné et les dégâts sont
parfois immenses
fait remarquable en 2020 les attaques
contre les services publics et les
collectivités ont sensiblement augmenté
les petites et moyennes communes sont
particulièrement vulnérables
mais les plus grandes aussi puisque en
mars dernier la métropole
d'aix-marseille étaient infectés par un
rançon j ciel qui à crypter près de 90%
de ces données plus inquiétant encore au
vu de la situation sanitaire cette
vulnérabilité n'épargne pas nos
structures hospitalières albertville
narbonne ou encore le chu de rouen en
novembre 2019 qui a été entièrement
paralysé pendant plusieurs jours
si fort heureusement la santé des
patients n'a pas été mise en péril
à l'avenir des cybercriminels plus
malveillant encore pourrait tout à fait
modifier les données des analyses
médicales ou des dosages bloquer le
fonctionnement d'appareils médicaux ou
chirurgicaux conduisant à des
conséquences dramatiques pour les
patients hospitalisés
à l'heure où nous hôpitaux sont
surchargés par l'épidémie coville 19 un
tel risque est effrayant
madame la ministre la vulnérabilité
cyber dans notre pays
en fait une proie facile pour les
hackers c'est une menace de tout premier
ordre
que comptez vous faire pour que nos
entreprises et nos services publics
puissent se prémunir de ce risque
au delà des actions pédagogiques
qu'elles font comptez vous mobiliser
pour financer la nécessaire mise à
niveau des systèmes de protection
informatique et notamment ceux des
services de santé et des collectivités
territoriales je vous remercie pour vos
réponses la parole est aux nominés
chargé de l'industrie madame pénurie
lâcher merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur saurai vous avez
raison de souligner l'augmentation de la
menace cyber puisque les incidents de
sécurité déclaré alan si notre agence de
protection en la matière qui est
extrêmement compétentes et réputé au
plan international a été multiplié par
quatre comme vous le savez il ya trois
types de menace la cybercriminalité je
mets la main sur vos données et je
demande une rançon
l'espionnage et le sabotage et ses trois
menaces doivent être prises très au
sérieux au même niveau
l'espionnage et le sabotage concernant
plutôt les entreprises ou les structures
de recherche et développement les
universités nous avons avec le ministre
de l'intérieur le ministre le secrétaire
d'état au numérique cedrico signé un
contrat stratégique de filière avec les
industries de sécurité en 2018 est
élaboré un certain nombre un comité un
contrat de stratégique de filière en
2019 pour notamment faire en sorte que
notre offre en matière de sécurité cyber
soient augmentés nous avons un
écosystème de start up de grands groupes
d'université qui ont des briques de
réponse à cette menace mais qui doivent
être mises ensemble pour être porté à un
niveau mondial c'est à la fois un enjeu
de services numériques un enjeu
industriel est évidemment un enjeu pour
le ministre de l'intérieur qui est à la
fois comptable de la fraude et du suivi
de la fraude et des cybercriminels et
qui est en train de monter en puissance
sur ces sujets là mais également qui
apporte avec les services du premier
ministre et lancy tout un appui aux
collectivités locales et aux structures
hospitalières pour les aider à passer un
cap en terme de compétences et en termes
de matériel donc je veux vous rassure
ici ce sujet est pris très au sérieux
vous savez que nous allons annoncer la
semaine prochaine une feuille de route
sur notre stratégie cyber qui sera
financée de manière très importante par
le pays à quatre
je laisserai en découvrir les projets
principaux la semaine prochaine c'est un
enjeu interministériel sur lequel nous
sommes tous mobilisés
monsieur saurai si vous souhaitez
quelques secondes effectivement c'est un
sujet de premier ordre qui nécessite une
réponse rapide et efficace et vous
n'avez pas donné des éléments qui me
rassure complètement j'espère pouvoir
les avoir dans les semaines qui viennent
je remercie mais aussi la parole et à
notre collègue philippe bonnecarrère
pour le groupe de l'union centriste
avait la parole monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues
monsieur ministre de l'éducation
nationale en 2020
vous avez annoncé un moratoire sur les
fermetures de classes à la rentrée la
semaine dernière interrogée sur la
rentrée de septembre 2021
madame la secrétaire d'état a annoncé
dans cet hémicycle à moratoire de fait
pour les communes de moins de 5000
habitants sans l'accord du maire les
élus locaux ont considéré le moratoire
comme acté et je ne vous cacherai pas
que la vidéo de la semaine dernière a eu
un grand succès sur l'ensemble des
territoires
mais les projets de fermeture se
poursuivre en réponse tout à l'heure à
notre collègue madame brulin vous n'avez
pas voulu vous engager sur un moratoire
tout en nous présentant quelque chose ne
s'humilie si je pouvais résumé qui s'en
rapproche
vous avez les moyens d'un moratoire avec
la baisse de 65 pb lève vous avez les
moyens d'augmenter le nombre
d'enseignants dans les classes devant
les élèves
et c'est heureux pourquoi ne pas dire
plus clairement les choses donner
confiance et prononcé monsieur le
ministre le mot moratoire
pour vos réponses on a parlé tout vise
l'éducation nationale de la jeunesse et
des sports monsieur blanc caire où ils
avaient la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur bonne
carrière
je vous remercie de votre question et de
donner acte du fait qui est visible par
tous que nous créons des postes comme je
le disais tout à l'heure alors même
qu'il y à des élèves en moins si je
prends le bilan depuis le début du
quinquennat ça signifie pas loin de dix
mille postes en plus sur la totalité du
quinquennat
là vous avez plus de deux cent mille
élèves en moins pour avoir une politique
quantitative certes mais surtout
qualitative pour une série de mesures
comme par exemple la limitation pour
toute la france du nombre d'élèves à 24
en grande section au cp et on sait rien
ce qui sera le cas dans votre
département du tarn si je prends
l'exemple du département du tarn à la
rentrée prochaine si on prenait en
compte la baisse démographique et bien
il y aurait dix neuf postes en moins
dans ce département
ce ne sera pas le cas n'y a pas de
suppressions de postes dans le tarn
doit-on pour autant faire un moratoire
sur la fermeture de classes et d'écoles
vous savez que les deux sujets sont
différents et vous le savez bien je n'ai
aucun problème pour prononcer le mot
moratoire pour école parce que en effet
notre politique est une politique de
défense de l'école rurale j'ai souvent
eu à le dire devant le devant le sénat
et je suis fier de cette politique et
nous avons à la mener ensemble ça doit
être d'abord une politique
d'attractivité de l'école rurale qui
fait réussir les élèves en effet et ça
passe par exemple par le fait que dans
le plan de relance avec le premier
ministre
on a mis plus de 150 millions d'euros
sur l'équipement numérique des des
écoles et sa bénéficiera notamment aux
écoles rurales
cette attractivité est fondamentale le
mot moratoire pour les classes est
beaucoup plus difficile à prononcer
pourquoi vous le savez bien c'est que il
s'agit pas de faire des économies mais
si je prends l'exemple du tarn
si on ne supprime pas de classe alors
même qu'on supprime pas de poste ça
signifie qu'on aura dans un certain
endroit des classes à 30 et dans
d'autres des classes à 10 soit 15 et ce
serait une inégalité de fait et vous
seriez le premier à raison de vous
plaindre cette souplesse elle existe
depuis toujours en nombre pour la
rentrée 2020 nous avons fait une
exception pour tenir compte de la crise
sanitaire
si nous le faisions année après année on
créerait des hétérogénéités qui ne
serait pas souhaitable
en revanche oui il faut plus de postes
pour l'école primaire c'est la politique
que nous menons et elle permet pour
votre département comme pour tous les
départements
l'amélioration je les dis historique du
taux d'encadrement dans votre
département comme dans chaque
département de france
si votre carrière oui monsieur le
ministre nous ne comprenons pas comment
avec moins d'élèves et autant
d'enseignants si ce n'est plus nous
puissions avoir sur le terrain plus de
fermetures que d'ouvertures
pensez également au jour d'après le kof
20 19
et cette idée que ruralité petite ville
seront vus demain comme une alternative
pertinente à la métropolisation
nous ne voulons pas nous amener un petit
peu plus loin dans vos décisions
merci
[Applaudissements]
un parent le cas notre collègue étienne
blanc pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole je viens merci
monsieur le président monsieur ministre
de l'intérieur les chiffres de
l'insécurité dans notre pays se dégrade
et il en est un qui inquiète tout
particulièrement les français c'est
celui qui résulte de la constitution de
vendre particulièrement dans les parties
urbaines ou périurbaines de notre
territoire
le chiffre est inquiétant puisque sur
l'année 2020 et les agressions commises
par ces bandes ont augmenté de l'ordre
de 25% et ce sont 350 bataille que se
sont livrée entre elles ces bandes
ces chiffres inquiètent relais français
parce que ces bandes elles sont souvent
constitués par des mineurs par des
adolescents qui n'ont plus aucun repère
moral
la violence des actes qu'ils commettent
sous les caméras sont là pour le
démontrer
c'est aussi inquiétant parce que on le
sait ces bandes sont en connexion avec
des réseaux divers stupéfiants armes ou
prostitution et c'est enfin terriblement
inquiétant parce qu'elles savent
aujourd'hui utilisé les réseaux sociaux
notamment le darknet pour se constituer
pour agir et pour ensuite se dissoudre
face à ce phénomène il faut bien avouer
que l'on ne voit pas la politique
spécifique que le gouvernement entend
mener on a même le sentiment parfois
qu'il est un peu fataliste non chalon et
passifs devant l'importance du phénomène
monsieur le ministre l'intérieur il
s'agit
d'une délinquance spécifique qui doit
appeler des politiques spécifiques
est-ce que vous pouvez aujourd'hui nous
dire quelle politique spécifique vous
entendez mettre en oeuvre pour lutter
contre ce phénomène particulièrement
inquiétant maëlys de l'intérieur au
sujet robert mona le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs de ce
sénateur l'on vous avez tout à fait
raison sur la question très inquiétante
des bandes 70 bande à peu près sont
recensés dont 95 % d'entre elles sont
dans la plaque parisienne et c'est un
point évidemment très important qui
était illustrée par le drame de la
serrurerie dont je voudrais ici dire à
quel point les services de police chacun
l'a remarqué ont été rapides et
efficaces dans les interventions géant
merci ce n'est pas tout à fait vrai
cependant noces le sénateur que les
chiffres de la délinquance sont
mauvaises
ils sont mauvais vous l'avez dit en zone
gendarmerie ce qui a permis de répondre
à une question ici même voilà quinze
jours et il s'améliore fortement dans
les grandes villes de france à
l'exception de quelques centres villes
que vous connaissez bien et dont vous
êtes par ailleurs élu c'est tout à fait
vrai lutter contre les bandes
c'est d'abord lutter contre les
nouvelles technologies et chacun doit
comprendre ici les parlementaires de la
nation que si les écoutes téléphoniques
par exemple aide à lutter contre la
délinquance d'hier les réseaux comme moi
tu zappes comme télégramme com signale
les réseaux sociaux que vous avez
évoquées ne sont pas dans le scope du
ministère de l'intérieur il faut que le
parlement réfléchi à cette question
c'est ce que nous proposerons dans la
loi citée dans la loire enseignement qui
arrive dans quelques semaines désormais
ceux-ci l'uteq des images plus
performantes les caméras de
vidéoprotection vous le savez plus
personne ne doute du fait qu'elles sont
efficaces et qu'elles permettent de
résoudre à sa demande le conflit voire
de les prévenir mais aujourd'hui c'est
les drones qui fonctionne et qui
permettent une intervention plus rapide
et de suivre des phénomènes demande
comme vous l'avez évoqué c'est justement
la proposition de loi sécurité globale
qui arrive aujourd'hui je vais saluer le
sénateur hervé qui s'occupe
particulièrement de ce texte pour le
sénat pour améliorer et donner à l'état
miss à l'intérieur les moyens de
superviser ces bandes et de les suivre
et la cnil a aujourd'hui donné un avis
négatif pour pouvoir faire voler ses
drones et nous attendons le vote du
sénat pour pouvoir reprendre
évidemment sa surveillance car personne
n'imagine de faire fonctionner sans les
drones et de lutter contre ces violences
évoquée par les deux bandes et puis
c'est souvent des très jeunes enfants
monsieur le sénateur 12 ans 13 ans 14
ans alors on peut en vouloir au
ministère de l'intérieur on peut aussi
se dire que c'est travail des parents
monsieur blanc quelques secondes si vous
souhaitez intervenir en brièvement pour
réitérer que la réponse à ce phénomène
c'est une réponse de coordination entre
les différents points que que vous avez
soulevés et qu'évidemment le sénat sera
extrêmement attentif à ce que vous
proposerez compte tenu du dérapage que
nous connaissons
notamment dans nos grandes métropoles
qui inquiète profondément les habitants
de nos villes
la parole est maintenant notre collègue
serge mérillou pour le groupe socialiste
écologisme et républicains la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation
à plusieurs reprises le président de la
république a dit des agriculteurs
pendant la crise sanitaire qu'ils
étaient des héros de première ligne
monsieur le ministre les héros sont
fatigués car au delà des belles paroles
les actes ne suivent pas le monde rural
les agriculteurs et notamment les
éleveurs sont en grande difficulté
faiblesse des revenus déception de la
loi et galim lourdeur des procédures
administratives aléas climatiques
économiques et sanitaires
bref rien de leur épargner beaucoup trop
d'agriculteurs en vivent dans la
précarité et la profession connaît un
taux de mortalité par suicide très élevé
mais la précarité touche aussi les
retraités agricoles qui ont travaillé
dur toute leur vie cinquante cinq heures
par semaine c'est les chiffres de
monsieur le ministre pour eux une petite
lumière se profiler au bout du tunnel
avec l'adoption en juin dernier dans la
souffrance et après trois ans de débats
de la proposition de loi sur les
retraites agricoles
si celle ci était imparfaite en oubliant
le sort des polypensionnés des formes
conjointe
permettait néanmoins de revaloriser le
montant minimum des petites retraites de
120 euros par mois pour atteindre au
mieux 1000 euros huit mois après le vote
de cette loi et malgré les discours et
les postures les décrets d'application
ne sont toujours pas parus et les
retraités agricoles n'ont pas touché un
centime de cette revalorisation
pourquoi attendre alors que cette
réforme pourrait aider dès aujourd'hui
de nombreux agriculteurs en grains de
retraités agricoles en grande précarité
alors monsieur le ministre la question
est simple quand allez vous signer les
décrets d'application de cette loi devra
entériner ces avancées même modeste pour
les retraités agricoles de l'agriculture
de normandie merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le le sénateur je
pense qu'on peut me faire beaucoup de
reproches mais pas être dans le discours
la posture depuis que ce gouvernement a
été nommé si je ne prends que les
actions sous l'égide du premier ministre
c'est plus d'un milliard deux que nous
avons engagées dans le cadre du plan de
relance est un discours très ferme sur
la création de valeur c'est une
démultiplication des contrôles dans le
cadre de la loi et galim et c'est une
volonté très forte qui est de recréer de
la valeur parce que la première des
priorités c'est le revenu de nos
agriculteurs
alors votre question porte monsieur le
sénateur sur un point très précis qui la
retraite du monde agricole
la loi est très claire elle et il faut
que cette réforme soit mise en oeuvre au
plus tard au 1er janvier 2022 nous
serons prêts et je vais même vous dire
notre objectif avec madame la ministre
elisabeth bornes c'est d'avancer le
calendrier
je suis très clair c'est même d'avancer
le calendrier par rapport à ce que la
loi à voter pourquoi monsieur le
sénateur
d'abord parce que c'est une question de
justice sociale et vous l'avez très bien
dit cette question de justice sociale
elle a fait l'objet de beaucoup de
débats défendu ici dans cette haute
assemblée
et tout le monde s'accorde à dire que
cette question de justice sociale devait
être traité comme la loi l'a adopté et
donc nous la mettrons en oeuvre et
encore une fois je vous le redis notre
objectif est d'avancer et le deuxième
élément qui est très important c'est que
aujourd'hui on parle du revenu des
agriculteurs vous connaissez mon essai
mon obsession sur la création de valeur
il ya un point qu'on met jamais en
valeur dans notre agriculture c'est le
foncier
on a on aimait mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
l'un des pays d'europe où le foncier est
le moins cher et pour autant quand vous
êtes jeunes agriculteurs la première
action que vous faites c'est de vous
endetter à hauteur de plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros pour
devenir et pour devenir propriétaire de
votre foncier pourquoi précisément parce
que vous avez un doute sur votre
retraite
le fait de régler la retraite c'est de
la justice sociale mais c'est surtout un
élément structurel pour permettre
l'installation de nos jeunes
agriculteurs c'est tout le fil de la
politique que nous menons
merci la parole et valeur notre collègue
catherine belrhiti pour leur offrir
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des sports
monsieur le ministre la question est
tellement importante que j'y reviens
comme mes collègues je rencontre
régulièrement les maires de mon
département
ils nous interpellent actuellement sur
les éventuelles fermetures de classes
sans leur avis entre les inspecteurs
d'académies et recteurs les secrétaires
d'état et vous même les discours
divergent
monsieur le ministre en mars 2020 vous
aviez déclaré à la télévision vous
engagez à ne fermer aucune classe ni
aucune école rurale sans l'accord du
maire vous ajoutiez il est important de
préserver et de persévérer dans cette
logique de soutien questionné ici même
la semaine dernière madame et limaces
confirmer vos propos pour la prochaine
rentrée
aucune fermeture de classe ne s'est
faite sans l'accord du maire il n'y a
pas de raison que cela change
ses réponses devant la représentation
nationale sont sans ambiguïté pas de
fermeture de classe est un portier rude
école sans accord du maire
malheureusement l'administration que
vous dirigez ne l'entend pas de cette
même oreille et avance avec une pratique
exactement inverse les cartes scolaires
qui sont en cours de validation sont en
opposition complète avec les engagements
pris par le gouvernement suscitant
incompréhension et colère les fermetures
de classes met en difficulté les enfants
les familles les enseignants les maires
et les dden même dans le contexte
sanitaire actuelle et au moment où les
territoires ruraux connaissent une
nouvelle attractivité
on ne pouvait que se réjouir de
l'annoncé de votre décision permettant à
la rentrée 2021 de se dérouler dans les
mêmes conditions qu'en 2020 monsieur le
ministre
de deux choses l'une où cette situation
illustre la complexité cher au président
de la république du en même temps ou
force est de constater que les
instructions que vous donnez à paris
peine à être entendu sur le terrain dans
les deux cas c'est votre crédibilité
vis-à-vis des élus locaux qui est
bousculé
monsieur le ministre quel est à ce jour
la réalité des engagements du
gouvernement
pourquoi un tel fossé entre la parole
nationale et les actes sur le terrain
le ministre de l'éducation nationale
monsieur blanc caire merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs même la sénatrice belrhiti je
vais donc repréciser la doctrine pour
que ce soit très clair je suis
d'ailleurs le premier ministre de
l'éducation nationale pouvoir dire des
choses aussi bienveillante généreuse
vis-à-vis de l'école rurale puisque donc
c'est très clair pas de fermetures
d'écoles sans l'accord du maire
donc c'est très clair vous pouvez bien
l'enregistrer s'agissant s'agissant des
classes je vous répète ce que je disais
aux sénateurs bonnecarrère c'était une
mesure pour septembre 2020 vous avez
aimé premiers cités en mars 2020 le 10
ans pour la rentrée suivante et même à
ce moment là je disais que ça ne
pourrait pas se faire les années
suivantes je disais même en pensant à
ceux qui viendraient tout au long des
années suivantes ce serait un très
mauvais service à rendre à qui que ce
soit cas d'actes et que pour faire un
moratoire à jamais sur les fermetures de
classe sinon vous vous ôter toute
souplesse dans votre département madame
la sénatrice
il y à 1277 élèves en moins c'est cela
qu'il faut déplorer évidemment et vous
aurez 56 postes l'année dernière + 6
postes cette année
autrement dit nous continuons à créer
des postes malgré les fermetures
est ce que ça signifie à bagré le mall
la base élèves est ce que ça signifie
qu' il n'y aura pas de fermeture de
classe
si dans un endroit il ya quatre élèves
bien sûr qu'il faut fermer une classe
c'est une évidence donc il faut faire du
qualitatif et s'il y a une consigne et
les respecter et quand elle ne l'est pas
dites le moi c'est bien entendu à chaque
fois discussion avec le maire pour
prendre des mesures de bon sens mais ne
ne jouant pas ne pas nous comprendre
vous savez très bien je suis en soutien
complet de l'école rurale et le
l'ensemble du gouvernement l'est nous
voulons le renouveau de l'école rurale
il ya un sujet démographique il ya un
sujet d'attractivité nous devons
travailler ensemble c'est le sens et le
sens des stratégies que nous avons qui
sont explicites dans nos plans
départementaux ruraux pour l'école que
nous avons d'ailleurs conçu avec des
sénateurs
jusqu'à aujourd'hui nous allons
continuer et nous allons continuer aussi
avec des mesures qualitatives par
exemple les décharges pour les
directeurs
vous le savez vont être meilleurs à la
rentrée prochaine les mesures que j'ai
annoncée de limitation du nombre
d'élèves par classe en grande section cp
ce1 s'implique dans votre département
la rentrée prochaine donc nous
améliorons la vie quotidienne de l'élève
avec des moyens en plus pour le premier
degré faut complètement de bon sens mais
aussi de consensus avec les acteurs
locaux
quelques secondes en amérique monsieur
le ministre le retrait de classe ou de
postes d'enseignants contribue au
sentiment d'abandon des territoires par
l'état les français sont durement
éprouvé par la crise sanitaire nous
avons besoin de plus de cohérence et de
stabilité dans les annoncer dans les
faits pour retrouver la confiance
nécessaire dans la parole publique
indispensable à notre démocratie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
jean-marie janssen pour le groupe de
l'union centriste
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre de la
culture
vous le savez madame la ministre le
monde de la culture souffrent tout
particulièrement de la crise sanitaire
et la rigueur des mesures sanitaires qui
lui sont imposées ne sont pas comprises
des acteurs culturels ni du public les
métro et les bus sont pleins mais il est
interdit d'aller au théâtre ou au cinéma
même en respectant le port du masque et
les distances de sécurité les magasins
restent ouverts mais pas les musées si
le protocole est appliquée et respectée
pourquoi les établissements culturels
serait-il plus dangereux que d'autres
lieux tout aussi essentiel à nos vies de
plus en plus de nos concitoyens
connaissent un malaise psychologique
profond l'urgence sanitaire ne doit pas
masquer l'urgence culturel cela est
particulièrement vrai pour nos enfants
comment comprendre que nos écoles
restent ouvertes et que dans le même
temps les musées les cinémas les
théâtres où la salle des spectacles ne
puisse pas recevoir des petits groupes
d'élèves
dans ces conditions madame la ministre
le monde de la culture ne peut plus se
contenter d espoir vite déçu
vous avez estimé possible la réouverture
prochaine des musées et monuments et si
c'est la réouverture est possible selon
quels critères
allez vous annoncer un calendrier et des
modalités précises de réouverture et
allez vous en particulier permettent aux
lieux culturels d'accueillir des groupes
scolaires
je vous remercie madame la ministre pour
vous répondre
la parole quand madame roselyne bachelot
ministre de la culture madame la
ministre monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur janssen vous représentez un
département cher à ma collègue ministre
de la cohésion du territoire des
territoires particulièrement et marc
parent dont marc fesneau
pardon pardon rla particulièrement riche
en patrimoine en musée et en monuments
historiques et votre belle commune de
montrichard témoignent abondamment
effectivement la situation sanitaire est
encore instable même si elles
s'éclaircit sur certains critères
nous ne sommes pas encore complètement
au clair sur les perspectives
d'amélioration moins de cas de
contamination mais une surcharge
sanitaires importantes dans les services
de réanimation et des inconnus duo
variant c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons avec les responsables de
musées de monuments historiques tenu une
réunion lundi dernier avec le ministre
de la santé olivier ferrand pour bâtir
ensemble un certain nombre de conditions
de sécurité puisque les les conditions
sanitaires ont largement changé les
jauges la création d'un référent que
vides dans chacun des musées des
monuments les conditions sanitaires que
nous connaissons les protocoles qui me
paraissent bien adapté et pour la
question que vous posez sur les groupes
scolaires et l'éducation artistique et
culturelle
je souhaite évidemment bâtir un modèle
global qui fixe un cadre un cadre sûr
mais je souhaite aussi mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs car je sais que
vous y êtes extrêmement attachés faire
en sorte qu'il y ait de la souplesse et
que les territoires les responsables de
ces monuments
puis fixer des normes particulières qui
correspondent à leurs établissements
grand ou petit et de structure juridique
différente
c'est à ce moment là que l'accueil des
scolaires de toute façon ce sera après
les vacances qui vont se dérouler que
l'accueil des scolaires sera réglé selon
des modalités au plus près des
spécificités des territoires
si monsieur janssen vous y ajoutez
quelques jours
bien mais c'est le premier ministre
faisait messieurs les milices merci nous
avons terminé avec des questions au
gouvernement
nos prochaines questions d'actualité au
gouvernement auront lieu le mercredi 17
février 2021
si on va être suspendue elle sera
reprise à ses autres ans pour le débat
sur les conclusions du rapport de la
commission denquête pour l'évaluation
des politiques publiques face aux
grandes pandémies à la lumière de la
crise sanitaire de la commune 19 et de
sa gestion
la séance est suspendue
[Musique]